Housing Department budget workshop and begin our budget workshop for the
Houston Public Library. In attendance we have Council member Tasha
Jackson, council Member Abby Cayman, council Member Leticia Plummer
and staff from Council member Tiffany Thomas and Ed Pollard's
office. All budget workshops will be conducted in
person. Only public speakers have the option to comment in
person or virtually 48 hours prior to the start
of all workshops. Presentation material are uploaded to
SharePoint and hard copies delivered to each council office.
All departments have been directed to provide written responses within
48 hours of the conclusion
of their presentation. To any questions posted by council members on
SharePoint, the Budget Workshop schedule is posted on the BFA
website. Questions from council members can be uploaded at any time during the budget workshop
process. Of course, the earlier the better,
which allows the departments plenty of time to provide responses.
All public speakers should be signed in to speak. If you haven't, please signed in
on my left, on your right. And my staff member Carolina will
be monitoring the public speaker's list. Public speaker's
questions should be directed to City Council. If a public speaker would
like responses to any questions, they should submit their question to their
district council member or at large members.
Council members, the 2023 budget amendment template
has been uploaded to SharePoint. And as Mayor
Turner mentioned, all council offices
discussions on the 2023 proposed
budget will be handled there. Only operational budget
related amendments will be considered. Policy amendments should not
be submitted and will be ruled out of order.
Amendments are due Wednesday the 25th,
a week from today. Today we will hear from the Houston
Airport System, houston Health Department and solid waste.
As a reminder, only people attending virtually
are public speakers. And we'll get to their questions after the presentations
and after the questions from council member. It's my honor and pleasure
to welcome Director Mario Diaz and
Curtisia Hampton. Did I do right?
Okay. Of the Houston Airport system to provide an update.
Good to see you, Director. How's everything?
This is going to be all about spaceport, right?
Shoot. Okay, welcome. Good to have you all.
Also, before we start yes, your mic is on. Like to welcome
staff from Council Member Amy Peck's office,
marianne Huffman office,
colossus Nero's office, and Council Member Sally Alcorn,
and staff from Vice Mayor Pro TEM Martha Castek Tatum,
and the lady who just came in because I parked next
to her, council Member Carolyn Nevin Shabbat and Vice Chair
Edward J. Pollard.
Mr. Chair, council members, welcome and thank you for the opportunity to share
with you our insights into the preparation for the 2023
fiscal year budget for the Houston Airport System. What I'd like to
do first is introduce the team. My team. As I've said
before, it is the team that gets things done.
In particular, I'd like to first introduce Jim Sesniak,
our new chief operating officer. I'm really, really delighted to have him on board
to help. We have Liliana Rambo, chief of Terminal
and also helpful with administrative matters.
Of course, you know Todd and you know Mayuri, the council liaisons.
We have James Stormsky,
who is the acting assistant director for Financial Planning.
We have Fruit Khan who is the budget manager. We have
Anna Guerrero and Uber Khan and Tanya Harris,
all three of whom are financial analyst force.
And they've all assisted in putting this presentation together.
And then next to me, of course, is Katisha Hampton
who will help me with the presentation. Now,
Katisha is actually the chief auditor for the department,
but since we lost our chief financial officer not too long ago,
I've asked Katisha to help out pitch in and she's gladly
done that. Of course,
Katisha really handles more of the accounting matters for
the department and I handle the financial analyses
and financial aspects of the
finance department. What we'd like to do today
is I would first like to take this in two parts. In the
first part I'm going to go through and talk about some of the accomplishments
and some of the forecasts and projections that formulate the basis
for the budget itself. And then Kirtisha will
go through the numbers. So, next slide please.
And of course we'll take questions. So the
first slide shows the budget cost centers for the department.
As you can see, we are proposing a total budget of $516.7
million that's total revenue and total expenses and
flow of to the
airport infrastructure fund. We have a
total of 1152 employees
or full time equivalents, and we have eleven cost centers.
Next slide please. When it
comes to accomplishments, I think there are just three that I want to highlight
and there is one Mr. Chair on the spaceport. Be patient
and we'll get to it in a second. First of
all, and this is the most important,
and it is that we've established Hobby as a five star
airport, the first five star airport in
all of North America by Skytracks. It is the first of the
60 odd airports that are tracked by Skytracks.
And it is really important because it gets us to half of
the way to our vision. Remember that the vision of the Houston
airport system is to create a global air service gateway where the magic of
flight is celebrated. The airport system has
two commercial airports. We have the spaceport, but it's
not a commercial airport. We have two commercial international airports, both of them
international. And we have accomplished the mission of becoming
a five star airport at Hobby. We are
now focusing with all our energy and focus
on intercontinental, to make that a five
star as well. Now this brings us, of course, to a
very, very special place in world airports. Only 16
airports, 15 and ourselves at Hobby are
rated five stars around the world.
And it's an accomplishment, as I say. That brings us to the point where we
can now say the vision we are halfway there on the vision
of becoming a global air Service gateway. Next.
The next that I would like to focus on
is the accomplishment of itrip. That is the International Terminal
Redevelopment Program. Construction has accelerated.
We are very well into the
ground. We will be coming out of the ground with steel probably
in the June, July time frame,
the Deep West Pier. And you'll see if you come
to next Thursday's Economic Development Committee, we will be putting on
a presentation devoted totally to the
International Terminal Redevelopment Program. And we will be
featuring a section of that of concern that I know is probably
on your minds today, which has been on our minds, which is the roadway congestion.
So we'll address those things.
The D West Pier, which is going to be the first installment
to be completed, will be delivered on schedule in June,
July of next year, that is, we will have a brand new pier.
The rest of the renovation of the North Terminal
will be completed by December of next year. And then in the June July time
frame for 2024, the entire project will have been
completed.
We are due to,
as I say, make a presentation to the Economic Development Committee on
the status, the complete status. And really, it's to talk
about the scale of this project. And you're going to see some slides when we
come in next Thursday of the huge structures that we've got
to bring in and lift into place to make this project
happen. The third accomplishment
that we're very, very proud of has to do with the spaceport.
Next slide, please. So in the
spaceport, we have been really,
it can't be said in any other way, more successful than
we ever imagined we would be with this spaceport
having completed and brought into the spaceport
system three top companies that
together will, in a matter of 15 to 18 months,
have about 650,000
manufacturing space in the aerospace sector. These are collins
Aerospace, of course, is the division of Raytheon Fortune 500
company. We have intuitive machines that will be building the Nova
Sea lander rocket propulsion systems. They're going to
the Moon later this month, the first commercial trip
back to the Moon. And it will be from a company that actually produced the
landers and the propulsion system and navigation systems right here
in Houston. And, of course, we have Axiom Aerospace. Axiom,
as you may know, on May 21 excuse me,
April 21 completed its first flight
to the space station, delivering astronauts and
coming back. And, of course, last week, May 11, we had the
groundbreaking ceremony for Axiom at the Houston
spaceport. So we think that
the addition of these companies, the addition of this 650,000
manufacturing space will result in about 1000 to
1500 jobs, new jobs, well paying jobs within the
next 15 to 18 months.
Next slide, please. So what does the department do?
Well, I think our mission statement sums that up very, very nicely.
It is that we exist to connect the
people, the business cultures and economies of the world
to Houston. Today, we provide about 184
destinations. From Intercontinental, 121 are
domestic, 63 are international.
From Hobby, we provide 84 destinations.
76 are domestic and eight are international.
At Intercontinental, domestic travel is exceeding international
recovery, 90% versus 77%.
The reverse is true at Hobby. At Hobby, we're recovering faster
in the international 91%. And by the way, these are percentages of
2019 traffic, 91% versus 82%
for domestic. We have four airlines that are exceeding
their traffic levels at IH against
2019. So they're doing better, actually better than they
were in 2019. We have four airlines that are
still in the recovery phase. We have one airline that's
gone bankrupt, was Interjet. They simply couldn't make it.
And we have two airlines, Ethiopian and Air China,
that have not returned yet. But we expect Ethiopian Airlines
to return probably in the summer of this year. And hopefully Air China
will be not too far behind. And then,
despite the Pandemic, we're very, very happy to announce that
airlines like Allegiant, Frontier,
Southwest, American, Caribbean Airlines, delta, Spirit,
Suncountry, United, Viva, Airbus, and Veladis,
all added flights, all added service during the
Pandemic that we have just transitioned through.
Next slide.
So our strategic plan is fairly
simple. It's laid out, as I said, there's the mission,
and I've talked to the vision. What we are focusing
on is acting responsibly with
respect to social, environmental and
economic concerns. As I've mentioned, we are
generating jobs focusing on how to train the youth
of Houston for careers in aerospace manufacturing,
and improving the financial resilience of the airport system.
That goes to the second bullet, the International Terminal
Redevelopment Program, the Domestic Terminal Redevelopment Program that we're
going to launch as part of the capital program in the coming
year. And Southwest Airlines seven gate expansion
at Hobby are all platforms for future success.
And then, of course, we have collaboration with airlines, the federal agencies,
and concessionaires and contractors. All in addition to the
work that we're doing in shifting the culture within the organization that
addresses the final priority, which is to build relationships
and conditions
for betterment.
As you can see, what we really want to do
is in the next slide, please.
This slide shows traffic in
graph form. I'll have
a slide that comes right after this that'll simplify it. But you can
see the vagaries month by month,
year by year. We start with the
blue, which is the 2019,
and then from there, you descend down. I would
just point to two graphs on this. That is the one
for 2022, which terminates at 25.5
million. That's what we expect at the end of this year, June 30, when we
finalize the numbers, we'll come out at about $25.5 million,
25.5 million passengers. And then
for 2023, we're forecasting 29 million.
And that's just about 800,000 short of the 2019
all time high. Next slide, please. This slide
better shows the point that I was making about the
trajectory and the path that we're following. As you can
see, we started out in 29.8 million employments
in 2019, and then of course, we dropped off and
we bottomed out in 2021, fiscal year 2021.
And then we've been increasing to where at the end
of this year, we expect to be about 25.5 and next year 29.8.
And then we'll continue on from there.
And so that concludes my part of the presentation.
If there are no questions at this point, I'll turn it over to Katisha
and she will carry on with the numbers. Next slide.
Good afternoon. So I'm going to talk about revenues by fund.
Oh, lord. Sorry. Thank you. I'm going to
talk about revenues by fund. And I'm really going
to home in on our FY
19 actuals versus our proposed FY
23 because our FY 29,
this is more because we dipped down during the pandemic.
But we are expected to either
match or exceed 19 with our
revenues and expenditures and our employments. So in FY 23,
we propose our budget is about 516,719,000.
In FY 19, it was about 518.
So we're about 2 million under budget
for I mean, under revenues to match 2019,
which we're back on track. For FY 22, we had 478.
So our budget has increased about 8.1%.
And if you go to the next slide so
our budget has increased by 8.1% over
our FY 22 estimate. And our airline
revenues for landing and terminal rents are projected
to increase by 11.6 million.
Non revenues, parking will increase
by 12.1, ground transportation and
terminal concessions by 9.3 million.
And car rentals, about 4 million.
Revenues from facilities and other miscellaneous
revenues are projected to increase about 3 million.
And our other miscellaneous includes ground
rents, hangers rentals,
facility rentals, and interest income.
Next slide, please. We want
to show you our COVID related grants that the airport has
received. So and we've received about
460,000,000, which is 458,000,000
that we have received,
that we are eligible for sorry, that's available to us.
We've received as of April 30 of
2022, we received 295,000,000.
Of that, we've used the entire 295.
So we have about 169,000,000 still
available for us to use for our COVID
related grants.
Next slide, please.
And now I'm going to go to expenditures. So our
expenditures for FY 23,
we are proposed to spend the
516, 719. And we can
look at FY 19 we had our actual was
519 million. 519,000,000. So we're about
3 million below our FY 19 expenditures.
Next slide, please.
So our expenditure highlights,
we're about 4.4% increase
our expenditures and that is due to personnel
increase by 6.3 million.
Supplies and capital and supplies and non capital
equipment, we're going to increase that by about
0.2 million, about 200,000. Our contracted services
are increasing by 4.1%.
And we just want to point out here at the bottom,
we pay about 1.3 million and
3 million of our general fund is
services to the city for HPD,
fire rescue, HR, it legal
water and sewer, et cetera.
Next slide, please. So this is
the expenditures, the change
in every line item by category,
and I'm going to talk more about that on the next slide.
So next slide please. Oh, perfect, thank you.
So this is our FY 23,
which is our expenditures for
8012 I'm sorry, which is our capital improvement.
So it's about 26,000,001. Three six.
For our FY 23 and FY 19,
we're looking at about 3 million. And that is due to our
increase in all our 4%
increase in all our facility maintenance, our police,
fire, rescue act, aircraft rescue,
utilities, et cetera. Next slide,
please.
Our expenditure highlights. In our capital outlay
fund, which is our fund 8012,
our expenditures are projected to increase by
828.7% over our
FY 22 estimate. And that is mainly
driven by our replacement of our has,
our fleet vehicles and HPD
vehicles. We actually had purchased vehicles in FY 22
and we did not receive them. So therefore, they had to
be rolled over into our FY 23 budget.
So that is mainly the reason for such a high increase
in our capital outlay. And we had about 0.7
in our computer and hardware, computer hardware and
software, and about 0.5 million into our
furniture and equipment. And just
so I wanted to reiterate here, we're buying 25
electric FY F 150s that
those are in that fleet that will be rolled over for the FY
23 proposed budget. Next slide.
We wanted to break out our FY 23 budget,
personnel versus non personnel. And if you look
at non personnel, it was about 61%.
Fire rescue is the biggest portion of
our non revenue. But I also wanted to highlight
on our contracted services, so our contracted
services are a big portion of our non personnel
as well. And so some of our top contracted services
are our security contract, which is about 4.8
million, landscaping is about 1.6
million, smart cart is about 1.4 million,
and our asset management is about 6.2.6
million. Next slide, please.
Here is a slide on our budget history. If you
look at our FY 23 proposed budget
versus our FY 19, we are
pretty much on target with our budget versus our
actuals with our FY 19 year,
because that is going to be our year that we are comparing
FY 23 to because our passenger levels are
back around that level.
Next slide, please.
And again, we want to thank you for our
prep budget presentation hearing and to reiterate
that Hobby is the first five star airport
in North America. Any questions?
Yes, we have a number of council members in queue. We'll first go to council
member Abby Cayman. Thank you, Mayor Protem,
Director. Congratulations to you and the
entire airport system team, our partners at the airlines.
It's hard to know where to begin, right. With all of the success and progress
that's been made, whether it's at the spaceport or our traditional airports.
I wanted to just spotlight we have a lot of residents that
are continuing to enjoy the new child play area
at Hobby. When I was in there, I'm seeing it packed all the
time. That's great. The new pet areas.
Can you remind me? I believe you touched on it at the beginning,
but there's been a lot of headaches. Understandably so
around Intercontinental with all of the construction,
and you've been very responsive to those needs. But can you go back to
when residents can expect some relief there?
Sure. Thank you for the question, council member. And so again,
next Thursday, we'll have a much more in depth presentation. But let me quickly
tick off a couple of points. The first point that I
would make is that I think we're over the hump on this one.
If we could do it over, actually, we'd have to do
it the same way. Here's the problem. It's real estate.
The way that we might have done it had we had the real estate,
was we would have built temporary roadways and put all the traffic on the temporary
roadways while we did the construction. But real estate
doesn't exist. We're in a canyon. Once you get into those roadways,
you've got parking garages on one side of the street, and you've
got terminal building, and we've got to work in
those streets. I think people don't appreciate the scale.
And so please come next Thursday so that you can understand the scale and you
can see the huge structures that we're moving on
these caterpillars and actually lifting at night and
putting into place. We're just not
replacing the roof or replacing windows in a building. We are
completely redoing the entire international
building. But to the point precisely.
But to the point precisely.
As of June 6, we will have finished the elevators
in the international terminal. Why is this important?
Because we could not bring handicap
passengers down to the lower level to take them through the tunnels
to the other terminal buildings. And so what we're doing is,
once those elevators are in place, we will take the
buses that were outside that were transporting passengers,
and we will use those buses will be removed, and we'll
have another lane open that will increase the capacity on the roadways.
Number two, in July, United Airlines, as you know,
they're building that at the same time. And we
probably could have done a little bit better of coordinating with them on that.
But they're building this massive early bag short system because they really
want to grow in Houston. It's a 400 million dollar investment.
It's wonderful once they have it in place.
But they needed to take down the roadways, and they limited
to one lane. Now, they tell us that as of July,
middle of July, that lane will be improved,
and the departures lane will all merge so that traffic should
flow much more smoothly through that area. And then in October of
this year, that will be done. That project will be done, and roadways
will be cleared. June 6
of next year, we will have the first installment for the,
as I said, the Dwest Pier. And once that Dwest Pier
is opened, we will have a much better time and
movement of traffic off of the roadways on the north the
terminal into that area. And then come June,
July of 2024, the project is finished.
Now, that's not to say it's over, because immediately
we are now focusing on the infrastructure inside the
roadways. We're replacing all of the water lines, the water mains.
We've got to put in high pressure water, because once
we start councilman Robinson, you know that once we touch
a building, you now must meet the new codes.
And one of those codes means you got to be sprinklers. We don't have the
water pressure. And so the new early the enabling
project that we have for the water will provide tanks, provide new
wells and pumps that will and new lines that will be
able to keep the water pressure at high enough level to actually
sprinkle all of the buildings without having to have pumps and tanks in each
one of those buildings. So that will continue. And then next year,
we're going to be starting on the same project
just at the other end of the terminal. The terminal a redevelopment program.
It's another billion plus investment we need to make
because we need to continue investing for the airlines. They've asked
us for 17 gates. We have a plan. We will be
bringing that forward to Economic Development Committee as well. So I do think that
we are now really starting to see the light
at the end of the tunnel on this. And we hope that as the summer
progresses, things will improve continually.
If I could be placed back in queue. Council Member
Sally Alcorn.
Thank you, Chair. On page 14,
the $103,000,000 breakdown that you give to the that
goes to to the city, to the general fund. If I could just you don't
have to give it to me now, but if I could get a breakdown on
that. Sure. And and to Council Member Cayman's Point,
what what can we do in this budget cycle to help you
with the traffic situation? Is it HPD?
It's really hard to explain what you just explained to constituents
who call that's a lot of
moving parts. Is there anything else besides
just the things that have to happen to open up lanes that can
be done to steer traffic?
We tell people, take the train to A, we'll pick you up at A,
or get the Uber from A or whatever. I mean, what kind of practical advice
or what can we do during the budget cycle to help you.
I think that the one point that we try to make
over and over. And I know we do it lightly because
we don't want people to think that they've got to spend their life
at the airport, but come early so that
you have enough time to get to the traffic so
that you are comfortable that you will make your flight. And then here's
the second thing we're doing. One of the things that we've noticed is that what
we call irregular operations. So for example, let's say that we have once
the flights launch from Asia, they launch from Europe. They can't
stop. They've got to continue. Once they're over the North Atlantic or the Pacific,
you just can't tell those airplanes to return.
But let's say the weather changes and
we're now in a thunderstorm condition. Those aircraft
have to be held. They start circulating at altitudes of
about 1000ft. They're stacked one on top of another.
And of course, I was going to go pick up grandma or my wife
or my kids and they were supposed to arrive at five. Well, guess what?
The aircraft is still in hold position and now I am circulating.
So what we're going to do as one of the measures that we were taking
is when we see this condition, we're going to open up the parking garages.
We're going to just let people go in. We're not going to charge them.
We need to get them off the roadways. We need to find containment
areas where we can get them off the roadways. And that way the traffic will
circulate much better. Okay, great.
And just congrats on the spaceport stuff too. And on hobby.
I mean, that's the most and to me the most exciting thing going on in
Houston, Texas right now. It's really great.
Council member. Cayman.
Thank you. Chair Director just as we
talked about construction, I just want to highlight and we can discuss
offline the importance of as we're looking at new plans and new facilities.
We are now the hub of innovation as we've always been. But that's really our
thing. So I want to make sure that as we're building, our buildings
themselves are pushing the envelope in terms of sustainability,
resiliency best practices in
terms of environmental sustainability.
Really quickly, I wanted to recognize you all at
the airports we got an increase in the minimum wage to 15, which I
think is a really remarkable and important thing to recognize.
My hope is that you all will continue to look again. We've just passed at
the city paid parental leave,
going to the next step in terms of our Janitorial contracts,
our subcontractors, things like that, to push to make sure that everyone is included
in those things. And if you all could provide just offline
and we can submit the question and update on the progress in
terms of Janitorial pay and things like that, I would
appreciate that. Sure.
Finally, Council Member Alcorn asked it, and I'll ask
it a different way, given the constraints that the city continues
to face. I know the airports are succeeding.
They are doing very well. Are there any other needs that we should be
aware of that are coming up on the horizon that you want to flag for
us? I can't think of any.
You've been very supportive. We're very grateful, and thank you
for everything you're doing to support us on this.
Thanks so much. Thank you.
So, Director, nobody else in queue, I'll ask a couple
of questions. So I'm looking at your revenue page.
$517,000,000. Do we have any
additional funds that come in from FAA and all that kind of
stuff? Your budget is always
the most difficult one to understand because you have sources
of revenue and expenses all over the place that are not in the general
fund. So we don't have purview to it.
If you look at the CAFR, it has four line items every monthly,
and you can't get much with four line items. So I'm trying to dig
down into everything you have coming in, everything you
have going out, including the what's our
international stuff called hasdc
does not well, I know, but it still has
a revenue stream. I get it. It's a separate organization.
I get it. But when it has Houston Airport system on
it, then I feel somewhat I should
be knowledgeable, but no one knows anything about
them. Maybe that's way it's supposed to be, I don't know. But getting back to
my original question, on the revenue side,
517,
is there FAA money? What does that amount to?
You make a good point. So let's look what what this
budget addresses. General fund is what we call operating revenue,
right? Operating revenue. Let's talk about non operating revenue
from an accounting point of view. So there are a couple of more line
items on revenue that we would address or we would bring forward
for your attention. For example, the biggest of those, aside from
grants, we'll get to grants in a second. We'll focus on a second.
But the biggest non operating revenue that we have, of course,
is PFCs. So we collect 450,
and we just multiply 450
times 30 million employments. You're at 120,
some odd million dollars, 120 plus maybe
$140,000,000 of PFC revenue.
Now, it's restricted with respect to what we can do for it,
but we can use it for four purposes. Number one
is to expand the national Airspace system. That is, if we can use it for
runways, taxways and things like that. We can use it for terminal buildings.
We could use it to security, to enhance the security of
the airports. We could use for noise mitigation around the communities.
And we have spent some of that money, and we use it for competition to
bring in new airlines. So that's what the roughly
100 and 3140 million PFCs can be used for. And it's
very helpful. Principally, we. Use PFCs to
write down the debt service that we have to pay every year. That's how
we use the money. The second source of course, is in this case
for the past is the grants, the Cares Krisa
and ARPA grants. $450,000,000, that's a one off thing.
And as Katisha said, we've received about 300 million
of it. There's still about 160,000,000 or so to be
received and we're using those monies. We did use
about 92 million of that debt, as you saw on the line, of 120,
some odd million to assist the airlines
because to the extent that we use grants, they didn't have to pay the debt
service on that grant. But again,
the line share as you see on that page, is really
again to offset debt service. And for next year
we'll be using another 50 million and then another 50 million. And that'll
essentially use up the remainder of the grants that we have.
2nd, 3rd item is grants, FA grants.
So we receive. And we need to
do a better job because we think that there's more FAA grants out there to
be to be obtained, but roughly about
$50 to $60 million a year that we want to
bring in on an annual basis, either in terms of entitlements,
because we are entitled to grants on the basis of passenger
traffic and cargo that we move through our two airports. Our three airports.
And then of course, the last one is interest on reserves.
We have about a billion dollars in the bank and so
inflation is when interest rates rise. Of course
that becomes a fairly good source of additional incremental income.
So those four sources are not in these numbers, right?
And before we go, I know council Member David Robinson's in Q. Yes,
here's my problem, okay? And this is just a me issue.
I pride myself on trying to know everything about the financial
position the city is in, whether it's public works,
whether it's enterprise, whether it's general, whether it's airport, and nothing.
We have a guy who shows up here every other week. He has a name
very similar to yours and he sticks a microphone in front of all
of our eyes, ears and mouths with questions
that quite frankly we can't answer
and when we can't answer. And they show it, they love
showing it on the news to make us look like a bunch of idiots,
quite frankly. That's it.
That's part of the world we live in today. It's a lot different than,
you know, Walter Cronkite days, but there's a mission
and I feel so inept many times when I see
him out there and I run away from him because I know what questions he's
going to ask and it's going to be related to your enterprise and
I feel inadequate about answering it. I don't know how everybody else
around here feels, but that's just a me issue because there are
so many moving parts and you and I have had various conversations.
I've been here longer than anyone, and I trust you implicitly, and you do a
great job. And the Houston Airport System is
a well run, organized machine. Some of the
things we do there, especially what's going to happen down south,
is monumental. But FCC
money, general funds, revenue, all these different things.
And then a guy shows up with a microphone, and I just feel
unprepared many times. So that's why some of my questions dig
a little bit deeper. Ha SDC. I'd love to know
what more is there about the Houston Airport System Development
Corporation? We should be proud that we have airports that we
run, operate in Costa Rica, in other
parts of the world, nobody else is doing innovative things like this.
So I'd like to know more about it so I can educate
the public who votes for me or doesn't vote for me that they go,
look at that guy, he knows more about it. We trust him. But there are
many times I don't feel that way. But that's a me issue. David Robinson
I thought there was going to be a question at the end of all that
for the there is. Sounded like he might want to refer to my favorite architect.
Did you have anything you wanted to respond to? The chair the only response that
I would give is that we follow
the protocol. We follow the rules in preparing the budget and providing
information. If you would like a different format, if you would like
to expand the scope of the information, we'd be happy to
provide it. We're not looking to in any way shelter
or restrict information. We're just following the program here.
Right. And I think, Chair, that's part of the reason I wanted to hear that
preliminary answer, because frankly, my line of questioning was along some of
the lines you've pursued. And I've been fortunate enough to
travel with Director Diaz to some points
with mayoral delegations in South America.
We've passed through I've passed through not with you, but Ecuador,
Costa Rica. You've mentioned some of the investments that we have in the portfolio
of airports that we've assisted with globally. And it is
really something for us to be very proud about. And Director
Diaz, I think that is something that I share the Chair's interest
in knowing more and understanding about, but understanding
that that's outside of the budget, that you have
to operate your department.
That's kind of where I wanted to see if I could
take a moment and get your feedback on the extra
budgetary issues that I've heard you talk about already
today. There are capital improvements that
are going on at all three airport spaces in the city of Houston
right now. That's not what you use to run your department on
an annual basis, and it's really not what's in our budget.
And I'm thinking about how we,
with your help, could get to a better understanding how some of
those capital improvements go on concurrently while you're running
an airport system. And if you follow me, this is where
the things that the Chair and I have been on the news
along with you recently are problems,
whether it's congestion at the airport that you've addressed with
questions from Council today. I think I was recently
interrogated for why there weren't enough bathrooms
open. Did they interrogated? I think I did. And so the fact
that you didn't have enough bathrooms open became something that apparently
I should have known about. And I do care about the architecture that
you're investing in. And you know as well as I do that I've had some
serious questions for your design team, but that is,
again, extra curricular for you.
And as the director who I feel is the most scrutinized,
the most audited, and perhaps the most or
the least understood, I wonder if you could shed some light
on the separation of those basic components of
what you do every day.
I'm the chief executive for this organization called the Houston Airport System.
And right now, as I said, I'm very happy to
have Jim Sesniak, who is now the chief operating officer.
Jim made a very good point. We had our
enterprise meeting, quarterly enterprise
meeting with the entire organization. He made a really interesting point
that the CEO focuses on the organization
and the CEO operates within the organization.
So Jim's responsibly enrolled will be on the operational side
because the capital side of
this organization is
as large or not larger than the operational side.
When you really start to think about and again,
you'll see some videos. Last night we lifted in place
a section of truss that was 120ft in
length that was brought in on one
of those bogeys that was erected,
actually put in place right outside the airport because it
couldn't be transported. And we brought it in on 11:00
at night. They started and they finished at 03:00 in the morning.
Lifting this thing by huge cranes and putting it in place.
This is not a small operation. It takes
a lot of attention to details. Councilman, as you
know, when it comes to design, you talk about
design management. I've been the design manager
with your assistance, and we've taken a look, and I have
rejected many, many designs, many, many proposals. I've said,
no, that's not what we want. We want something better. I have
pushed the designers. I've put them in competition with one another, and they've
come up with a phenomenal design for that terminal build.
I think when this thing next year,
hopefully you will all come out for the ribbon cutting for the Dwest
Pier. You're going to see a pier that is the
first installment of a terminal that you've never seen
the likes of in this city. It's just going to be beautiful.
Absolutely and absolutely functional, because we
really want to pump a lot of traffic through there. Now,
having said that, I also have to focus on the finance
and I've got to focus on the business and chiefly the
negotiations with the airlines, because that's the difficult
part. Over the course of my
career, I've learned that you don't go into the office of a
CEO and say, hey, we want you to come to Houston or to
Atlanta or to New York. Well, New York is different.
Houston or Atlanta, and we want you to provide service and
you want to show them photos, because what they say to
me is, mario, those photos are really nice. What's the cost?
What's the increase going to be? How much assurance can
you give me about the control of costs in your airport?
What's the market? How's your economy going?
And you've got to be able to answer all those questions. So as the CEO,
I need to take on that role. And it's
difficult. It's something that it's not
a five day a week, nine to five job. It's a
day a week job.
It is. And thank you for that. And that's why we try and our
responsibility is to direct everything to you,
not to them. As a board of directors, sort of for the city,
we have to go right to you and we hold you accountable. We don't want
to go to your people. So this
is our big chance to get an opportunity to do that. Council member tarsha
Jackson thank you, chair. Thank you.
And my colleague, what he just mentioned, that trying to understand
the airport and their budget. I mean, airport is in district b. And so
it's been a challenge for me trying to understand your operation. And so I would
love to just spend more time with you guys so that I can just
be able to represent my constituents better.
And so hopefully we can do that soon in the future. But I do have
a question about the ARPA dollars. You mentioned that you give
the ARPA dollars to airlines. And I'm just trying to understand that. Do the
airlines apply for ARPA dollars themselves? No,
we did all the applications as the city of Houston,
department of aviation, houston airport system,
and all of
the cares act, the Chris act,
and the ARP act dollars were provided to us
by formula generally. The formula is
that there's a pot that the federal government has available for airports,
and you will get the proportionate share of that pot
relative or related to the proportionate share that your airport
in terms of passengers, represents to
the total passengers across the country. And that percentage we get,
we've done pretty well. And then the question is, well, how do you
use it? And you remember during the depths of the pandemic,
one of the questions that came up was how do we help the airlines,
how do we help the concessionnaires? And you can
see in the Krisa act, there's actually a line item out
for crystal concessions. And this is money that we were to pass
on. We couldn't keep it. This money that we had to pass on for the
concession years, which we did, which is about 24 actually,
total of $30 million. And then the rest of the money,
it's a question, we could use it for any lawful purpose
of the airport system. And we decided that one of
the best use of that money was to help our airline partners
to the tune of about $92 million. But that's it.
Now we move forward and we're spending the rest to carry our
contracts, our sky train parking contracts,
manage those, use that money for those, and then of course to write
down the debt service so that we get to a net debt service payment
that we can very well afford. Okay. Council member
Cayman. Thank you Chair. And to
Council Member Robinson's point, I appreciate that perspective, right minutiae
of the day to day versus overseeing all
that you are overseeing, which is again, not just
our airports and not just global expansion, but galactic
expansion, for lack of a better word. So I appreciate you,
I've never known you to be anything but responsive
directly to me, to staff, your staff included.
So again, I just want to recognize how
far we've come and the instrumental nature in which our airports
play. Again, it's under economic development because of all the
things we're doing, without the airports, we can't bring people in.
So just wanted to recognize that. If I might,
just one last point that I would make.
It's not about me. As I mentioned
at the groundbreaking ceremony, I might be the
idea guy, I might be the strategist, I might be the visionary,
but it's these individuals and the entire 1100
members of the Houston airport system that make happen
what has happened to this point. And I'm really, really proud of them.
They're the ones that get the job done. Thank you. Council Member
Sally Alcorn. Thank you Chair. And I think you addressed most
of this in your response to Council Member Jackson. I appreciate you having slide twelve
in here to talk about the Krisa and the ARPA and the Cares funding.
And I think I heard you say I was going to ask and
I'm always blown away by when he just blows a billion dollars in reserves.
I mean it was a billion dollars in reserves before the Pandemic. It's a
billion dollars in reserves now because
of this money. Correct? That's pretty much it.
And then this 162,000,000 left,
I think you said you're paying down debt with it and
honoring some contracts and we'll be covering the parking
contract. It's about $30 million. And then there's the sky train
contract as well that we will be covered. Okay. And then that's
the end of and then that's the end. Got it. Thank you.
So of the $207,000,000 of
debt, how much is that is related to itrip?
Very little. Very little. What is that mostly related now? We only,
I think, in 2021, we fixed out about 265,000,000.
That is, we transferred it from commercial paper to bonds.
And I think the interest rate on those was three and a half to 4%.
So there's not a lot. As a matter of fact, one of the things that
we will need to do again, from wearing the financial hat is
this summer and into fall, we will be undertaking a
financial feasibility study. Because sometime between now
and February of next year, we will need to be back into the capital markets
to draw down and fix out the commercial
paper that we spent today. We've got $350,000,000 of commercial paper.
We need to unload that, fix it, and then
secure another $350,000,000 to finish out the
financing for itrip. So I would say that by the end of,
let's say June, July of 2024, we will have fixed out and
again, the total amount in terms of bonds is
likely to be about $750,000,000. Total bonds, total cost
of I trip will be 1.3 billion.
1.3. Right. Okay. And expected
completion date June July of 2024.
2024. Yes.
And no other council members give me my last question. I know that always
tell people, if Houston Airport was a
company into itself, it'd be a Fortune 500 company. It's that big.
It's a money making machine. Billion dollars in
liquidity. Right. It's a very successful
business, but yet we're still
the city of Houston. And I understand recently good to have Jim here,
but I understand we lost a COO. I understand we lost our
CFO. That's why Ms. Hampton is probably sitting in your
ability to recruit and maintain employees, given the
dynamics of what we have to operate under.
So two things are happening. First is that,
as you all know, the great resignation is affecting
us all. And it's an employee market.
Employees are basically calling their shots. They're establishing what
they want in terms not just of pay, but also the benefits
that they're available. And then some opportunities are opening
up. So our chief commercial officer left to become
the CEO of John Wayne in California.
Let's talk about this for a second, because, again, building leadership
is also part of my job. We start out with
biodari. Baron Biodari, former COO. He's now
managing the world's busiest airport as the director of Hartsville
Jackson Land International. Lance. Little former CLO.
He is now the managing director,
seattle Tacoma. Right. Okay. I'm sorry. No,
I was answering Seattle Tacoma. Right. Yes. Seattle Tacoma. He was
awesome. He is now the managing director of Seattle Tacoma.
We had Ted Kitchens, who was formerly running Intercontinental.
He's running now an airport as executive
just outside of Boston. You have Perry Miller, who was
running manager of Hobby. He's now running richmond,
Virginia. And we now have Charlene Reynolds,
who came in very, very short sprint and is now managing
John Wayne Airport. And so when
it comes to the CFO, the gentleman
walks into my office and says, thank you for everything you've
done. I've learned how to sell and
finance debt in the capital markets. You got to pay me
for that now. I said, wait a minute. We did. We gave
you the education. Yeah, but I've
got a baby coming. I've got a new house. I need more money, and they've
offered me more. I can't match it. And so we just
need to move on, and Leticia
is doing a great job. Thank you. Yes.
I look at you and I would say you're closer to
your end of your career than the beginning of your career. So we're going
to be faced with where does the replacement for Mario Diaz come from?
Is that person internal or external? That's something to discuss on
another day. We have a number of public speakers that want to ask questions,
so thanks for the opportunity to get
into it. We could probably sit here for a couple of hours and talk
about airport because I'm sort of a geek. I find
what you guys and ladies do every day sort of fascinating
and always tell everybody, we'll be down in spaceport tonight.
We have our redistricting meeting at Space Center. And always
tell people, when we moved here in
1990, hobby was this little bitty sleepy airport to
the south of us. And now it's a huge international
airport that wins a five star international airport that wins great
awards 20 years, 30 years from now. Love to
envision what spaceport is going to look like because it's going to change the landscape
of that area with phenomenal engineering
jobs and opportunities and things of that nature. So keep
up the good work, team, and look for bigger and better
things for you in the future. And I would also recognize
Mr. Icken, who's very involved in your operations as well.
Maybe you'd say too much. Right, Mario? Thank you.
Okay, thank you. Thank you.
Dismissed. We'll have a couple of oh,
by the way, council member Robert Gay goes joined us and
now has another meeting.
Mr. Jason Oliver, I think, will be joining us virtually.
Star six. Yes. Good afternoon.
I'm really appreciative of the art I'm seeing throughout the airports,
especially local artists. I was in IH last week, and there's
one artist, Kane Smith, whose tapestry doesn't have a nameplate.
It's a small thing, but I just want to know who to contact
to make sure that's addressed, because I think it's important people know
the artists whose work they're seeing. And then I guess
this question is toward Council Member Martin.
Many of us are really concerned about the procedural change,
removing the public's opportunity to speak publicly to city staff
during these budget workshops. This is not consistent with previous
years and is now our only opportunity to do so after the
committee meeting. Policy change during the pandemic, which I hope will also be
reversed this change midway is a significant inconvenience for
those of us taking time out of our work day to participate. It seems
like this was your decision. Are you willing to resume the
normal policy that we started this budget cycle with? And if not,
please explain why public participation is being directly undermined
this year. Thank you for your comments.
If public speaker has any questions,
the appropriate process is for those questions to be submitted
to Share Point under your name through your council
member. Thank you. Now, that was a
question to you, Council Member Martin. Well, Jason,
I just answered it,
so that's enough. Next speaker,
we have Miss Sava Blanding.
Good afternoon. Good afternoon.
City council members. Last night, I had a conversation
with my husband about the day's budget hearing, as one does,
and I asked him how he would have responded, and he said, I would have
asked, what are you afraid of? He commented on how there were only seven constituents
asking questions about HPD. Yesterday, the first department
finished 14 minutes ahead of time. If time was really
an issue, it is upon the council to keep everyone to time. However, there were
at least three to four repeat questions about Mowing schedules. In the middle of
Rush public testimony, there was an unrushed conversation with another Houston Police Department
employee. This is not about time. To have given public speakers
a full three minutes would have only added 14 minutes,
which the General Services Department's punctuality provided.
Why is the public not allowed more time? What would those 14 minutes
have cost the city, other than at least a humble nod to democracy?
Regarding the airports, what are plans to improve public transit
to access the airports? And what are efforts to include and promote
more local businesses in the airport system, such as local restaurants and local retailers?
Thank you. Ms. Blandy. Mr.
Oliver had a question. 1.75% of
all of our vertical construction dollars go
to the arts within that facility. So percentage
1.75% of the total vertical spend
goes to the arts within an airport.
Your pictures, paintings, different types
of things. Council Member Ed Pollard. Thank you,
Chair. Thank you, Ms. Blanning, for coming. Again,
trying to get clarification on your statement
question, as it pertains to
the what are you scared? Part, is that directed towards council,
as in why we aren't allowing more time?
Yeah, I mean, I understand time is an issue, and nobody
loves punctuality more than me. If I'm running a minute, a meeting is
going to be like, 15 minutes. But we got 14 extra minutes because General Services
Department was punctual. And then it felt
like I was watching people run out the clock because there were literally three
to four questions that were exactly the same about Mowing schedules.
And then when it came to public comment and we're taking time out
of our day, it's 1 minute. We're rushed, we're not given
answers, and we're told just to submit it. What's the point of this?
We're supposed to be a democracy. Well,
I appreciate your comments. I think the main reason for everything is
to get the public clarification on any questions
that you may have. And sometimes the questions
and the answers go above the time that we reasonably
have. So we have the process in place that if the questions and answers
aren't provided in a timely manner, then you can submit those questions.
Because at the end of the day, as constituents, you all have
rights to know any answer to any question that you may
have. And so if the point is to ensure
that you get the questions answered, then we have that
ability to do that. And so I don't want to get
caught up too much in the different systems and process, because we all
may have different opinions and perspectives on that. But if
your end goal is to ensure that you have more information
and more clarity based on the questions that you may have,
then we do everything we can as a council to provide those
answers to you.
Council Member Jackson. Okay.
Yes. Thank you. Saba I mean, that was one of my questions,
was we have the airport here in the police department.
They should be able to answer the constituents questions. I would want to get my
questions answered. If I'm sitting here in this chamber,
I would like to get the questions answered. So I would like to understand why
isn't that possible? Can we next year schedule these
hearings for the workshops? An hour.
Each department spend an hour to give people time to get
their answers. I'll let you get their questions answered. You and come
while I go through the next and you all can discuss it back there
away from the public. That's not appropriate for the public. We'll have Mr. Broder butler
next. Or I'll join you back there.
Good afternoon. I have no direct
questions at this point in time in regards to the airport. I think that
the Houston Airport does an above
average job. In other words, it's not exemplary. But I am very proud
of my airport. I've gone through many in this country. But I
do have just one concern, and now I am getting
to a question. I'm from Northeast Houston, and I
would like since Houston first is an initiative, everything about this city
is an initiative. I would like to have asked the director, who is on the
other side of the door and probably on the fourth floor now, what would he
do? Or could he put a program together to make sure
that since his airport is in District B, where I
come from, that he puts a program together to try to get employees
that live within a ten to 15 miles radius of
his airport to increase on time, to increase his workforce?
But I don't get a chance to answer that question because he
talked about being a visionary. He talked about doing things that would build
up this city. And unfortunately, unless somebody
else can ask me about the vision of the director of the airports about
hiring practices, I can't get that answer.
So he puts on a program twice a year. I believe it is
out in that area because I live a little bit north of you and
I forgot what he calls it. But it's an opportunity
for prospective employer groups that
want to work for the airport to understand a little bit more
about that process and also the MWBE
process that should help those types of businesses,
also individuals who are looking for opportunities as
well. So he does do that in conjunction with
a number of folks within his airport. And I don't know where they
are today with it, but I'll try and find out because it just reminded
me because of COVID we haven't had many of those opportunities.
But it would happen literally twice a year that
he would put on a convocave that had
those opportunities for individuals as well as businesses in
particular in that area. Well, thank you for the answer. With all due respect,
the marketing of that doesn't get out to the basic level of people.
But I would also like to extend an additional request,
if you could ask him if funds allow, if time allows,
that he can increase it from two to four. In other words,
create a bigger net to cast more people. Because at this
point in time, using this great resignation,
you still got to bake the donuts, right? Do me a favor.
Send my district email, district e at
houstontx. Gov an address so I have
your email address and I will copy you
on the email I send to Mario Diaz asking that particular question.
One last note. You have a very exemplary staff every time I've interacted
with them. It's been a pleasure. Well, thank you for saying that. And there's one
of them sitting right here and I agree with you.
That concludes public speakers for Houston Airport system.